[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que ça vous intéresserait d'être
jugé par une machine présente des
avantages
enfin ça peut en présenter le premier
avantage batou toutes les demi-heures
août où toutes les heures vous avez un
jugement
au lieu d'attendre deux ou trois ans
puis de passer par le greffe est tout
bon et puis à des situations identiques
vous aurez toujours le même jugement
toujours toujours toujours une machine
d'accord et pour autant pour autant
l'être humain quelles que soient les
cultures d'ailleurs n'est pas prêt à ça
il accepte l'aléa de la justice je vous
assure que les gens que je vois vienne
plaident leur dossier et ils sont
absolument convaincu d'avoir raison et
ils sont de toute bonne foi et les deux
parties sont de toute bonne foi ils sont
convaincus d'avoir raison et pourtant
ils acceptent le fait que peut-être on
ne va pas leur donner gamme cause c'est
à dire cet aléa irréductibles
pensons-nous il est accepté et puis par
ailleurs il ya une autre espèce d'aléas
que les gens ne comprennent pas bien
c'est que un juge peut rendre une
décision sur une données factuelles sur
un dossier
et puis un autre juge sur le même
dossier même dessus varende une décision
peut-être contraire ou différentes
pire que ça le même juge peu à des
époques différentes rendre des décisions
ou une décision différente et ça des
gens ne le comprennent pas et je
comprends qu'il ne le comprennent pas
pourquoi parce que le juge est sensible
car à plein de choses il est sensible
aux données du dossier
bien sûr mais il est également sensible
à l'environnement sociologique il est
sensible au temps ça n'est pas forcément
le même homme à six mois ou un an de
décalage
alors que le dossier sera le même je
fais souvent ce parallèle avec
l'interprétation d'un morceau de musique
quand vous prenez une partition jouée
par deux interprètes différents souvent
je me dis mais ce sont les mêmes note
c'est la même harmonie c'est le même
rythme et pourtant j'ai l'impression que
les interprètes jouent des morceaux
différents et bien le droit c'est un
petit peu comme ça aussi dans une
moindre mesure mais un petit peu comme
ça alors comment est-ce qu'on a été
amené à réfléchir sur tout ça j'avais
entamé une réflexion sur les rapports
entre entre le droit et les
mathématiques
et puis j'ai rencontré une autre
personne qui a fait la même réflexion
qu'il y avait un petit peu d' avance par
rapport à moi dans la mesure où il avait
déjà réfléchi et déjà créer une start up
issue de la recherche publique start up
qui avait pour finalité d'essayer de
mélanger ces deux sciences et de voir si
on pouvait pas prédire si on pouvait me
d'élise et une décision de justice
donc nous avons travaillé ensemble et
nous avons construit une démarche
une démarche qui se décompose en trois
temps la première démarche ça va être le
temps des juristes
incontestablement cette période ce temps
va consister je m'en expliquerai a créé
et extraire des critères surviendrait
deuxième période on va
j'ai les juristes et les mathématiciens
de la fiabilité et de la crédibilité de
ces critères et la troisième période
sans conteste c'est la période des
mathématiciens je vous dirais
j'essaierai de vous dire ce qu'ils font
la première période je voulais dit c'est
la période des juristes
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ils vont par
contentieux on appelle ça un contentieux
mais un problème vous avez tous eu des
des problèmes juridiques
on va extraire des critères alors qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un critère bas un
critère c'est une singularité
c'est une façon de qualifier
c'est une façon de conceptualiser la
chose
d'accord ces critères on va en prendre
par dossier entre 40 et 140 150 et on va
surtout ces critères leur affecter une
valeur accor valeurs qui sera 0 1 2 3 -
mais on va leur affecter une valeur dans
un deuxième temps nous entamons la
deuxième période
ça va être la période où on va juger de
la fiabilité de nos critères alors quels
types de critères schématiquement trois
types de critères des critères que les
juristes appellent factuel et critères
de procédure et des critères de
contentieux je passe très vite sur le
critère factuel juste pour vous donner
un exemple de ce que peut appréhender un
juge et de ce qu'il va pouvoir donner à
une machine vous prends l'exemple en
matière juridique le temps le temps les
coulées du temps va entraîner des
conséquences juridiques
soit il va vous permettre de créer un
droit soit au contraire vous allez
détruire votre droit maintenant que j'ai
conceptualiser je vais vous prendre un
exemple vous êtes créances et d'une
facture
vous avez 5 ans pour la réclamer si vous
l'a réclamé au bout de six ans vous avez
perdu votre droit quand le juge
appréhende la date de départ
la date de fin ce qui s'est passé à
l'intérieur de cette période
d'accord eh bien le juge va donner ces
critères affecté d'une valeur à la
machine il va dire à la machine à partir
de telle date jusqu à telle date
le droit a été détruit sache le hockey
deuxième type de critère des critères
procéduraux alors ne vous arrêtez pas au
terme il est il est un peu abscons mais
vous allez voir c'est très simple c'est
tout ce qui fait que le juge instruit un
dossier
d'accord je vous prends un exemple il ya
deux parties qui s'opposent
il y en a une qui ne veut pas
communiquer un document d'accord
le juge va contraindre cette personne ou
cette société à délivrer le document
d'accord c'est un moment important dans
la vie juridique de dossiers d'un
dossier le juge l'appréhendent il faut
que je dise à la machine ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi ça s'est passé et ce qu'a
décidé le juge
d'accord 3e série de critères les
critères proprement de contentieux juste
en un mot nous travaillons sur plein de
contentieux on va simplement dans le
contentieux concernés par exemple
contentieux de la franchise on va
chercher tous les éléments juridiques et
qualificatifs de ce qu'est une franchise
et on va instruire la machine de ces
qualificatifs et de ces critères voilà
ça c'est la première partie vous voyez
bien que c'est essentiellement le
travail des juristes deuxième partie
deuxième partie bas c'est un peu la
recherche de la preuve par neuf
c'est à dire au niveau des juristes on
va aller voir la fiabilité de nos
critères c'est à dire qu'on va aller sur
une problématique donnée chercher ce que
l'on appelle la jurisprudence
c'est-à-dire ce que des jus
je ont déjà jugé par le passé quand la
démarche est assez conservatrice mais
elle est faite ainsi
et puis sachant le critère et les
critères qu'on a sorti et les valeurs de
critères à ce stade
l'intelligence artificielle ne va faire
que extraire et lire les critères je
voulais dit par contentieux on en a
entre 30 et 150
c'est à dire qu'elle est contentieux qui
sont nourris de critères et d'autres
pour lesquels il n'y a pas nécessité
là ça va être la preuve par neuf ou pas
de la fiabilité de nos critères
troisième étape c'est l'étape des
mathématiciens
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ils vont
modéliser l'aléa judiciaire c'est-à-dire
que par des formules par des algorithmes
ils vont essayer de modéliser non pas un
résultat parce que modéliser modéliser
un résultat ça peut être assez facile
mais je voulais dit au début ce qui est
difficile c'est de modéliser une
distribution de résultats c'est à dire
sur un même dossier donner un juge peut
rendre des décisions différentes
est ce que l'intelligence artificielle
nous permet de faire c'est justement de
dire attention sur cette données
factuelles sur ce dossier voilà
l'échantillon de décision qui peut être
vendu
alors une fois qu'on a fait ce travail
comment est ce qu'on sait si ça marche
ou pas de façon assez assez simple c'est
plus du bon sens je voulais dit par
contentieux on prend analyse des
décisions entre 300 et 10000 20000 30000
de façon humaine toujours mais par
contentieux on se réserve un certain
nombre de décisions vierge de toute
analyse
d'accord on les a pas analysé ce sont
les décisions sur le contentieux
concerne et non les a pas analysé on en
sort une on rentre les informations dans
la machine et la machine va nous
proposer sans juge virtuel qui vont nous
proposer une distribution de solutions
et une distribution de jugement après on
va voir le jeu le jugement on voit ce
qui a été décidé et on compare et on
arrive à un taux de fiabilité
entre 85 et 95 %
alors ça fait peur je fais pas peur
quel est le risque qui peut exister sur
la modélisation d'un aléa judiciaire le
risque ça peut être qu'on arrive à des
décisions uniformiser qu'on arrive à des
décisions qui sut type qui se situe
entre deux bornes pas très espacées et
qui est pas une jurisprudence vivante et
que le juge soit impressionné par les
résultats de la machine comme je l'étais
moi aussi ce risque je n'y crois pas je
n'y crois pas pour deux raisons la
première raison c'est que
jamais un juge n'acceptera aucune
machine d'une personne d'une structure
qu'un groupe de personnes ne lui dicte
ce qu'il a jugé
je leur fais confiance et puis la
deuxième raison c'est que la solution
qu'on propose elle n'est pas violente
on propose pas une décision qui va être
rendu
on propose une distribution de solutions
entre deux bornes
et là le juge pourra choisir où il situe
sa décision proprement dite d'accord les
avantages j'envoie des avantages
le premier avantage c'est un peu le
contre-pied de l'autre c'est ça permet
d'éviter des jugements complètement à
l'opposé dans un sens ou dans l'autre
ça permet aux juges d'être confortés et
de se dire sur tel contentieux sur telle
problématique jeu c'est en gros que les
décisions vont se distribuer de cette
façon c'est donc plutôt rassurantes
et puis l'autre atout extrêmement
important c'est que ça ouvre le champ
des possibles en matière de négociation
vous avez deux parties qui viennent et
qui veulent en découdre ya une partie
qui dit j'avais un contrat vous avez
rompu le contrat de façon abusive
vous auriez dû me donner un préavis ok
on va rentrer les données du problème
qui s'est passé entre ces deux personnes
et la machine veut dire bah écoute et
compte tenu des données que vous nous
que j'ai enseigné
voilà le panel et la distribution de
solutions un juge aurait dû ou donnerait
une entrer en voie de condamnation
sévère la condamnation à entre trois
morts et cinq mois de préavis
la solution vous l'avez la distribution
de solutions juridiques ou judiciaires
vous les avez vous voulez aller plaider
allez-y mais vous voulez vous entendrez
négocier vous savez bien où vous
trouverez votre point d'équilibré
c'est la raison pour laquelle je reviens
à mon plaideur du départ à qui on disait
non non non toute façon tu vas rien
comprendre au jugement des machines au
contraire au contraire l'intelligence
artificielle va permettre à tous les
intervenants de la justice de mieux
éclairer les plaideurs et de leur dire
les risques ou les chances et surtout
d'expliquer pourquoi ils vont risquer
une condamnation ou pourquoi ils ont des
chances de gagner leur procès c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'insiste vraiment
là-dessus parce que j'ai j'ai été
convaincu donc au départ j'étais un
petit peu sceptique et j'ai été
convaincu des résultats et surtout de ce
qu'on peut en faire et je ne pensais pas
qu'à ce point
l'intelligence artificielle pouvait
modéliser non pas là léa d'une décision
mais là les a enfin nous proposer un
panel de décision ces modèles immobilisé
presque l'imprécision de différentes
décisions de justice sur un même
problème et j'en étais convaincu et j'en
suis toujours convaincu
merci
[Applaudissements]